the property brothers they love a
holiday it's drew Scott and his wife
Linda taking us exclusively inside their
home turned winter wonderland is our
first Christmas in this house together
and it means so much to us that family
here with us my obsession with the
holidays starts around February I mean
we start thinking about Christmas even
before Halloween Drew and Linda spent
three weeks transforming their la home
into a real-life gingerbread house
complete with holiday bakery and a
Christmas conveyer belt we basically
took the chain and pedal from a bike we
attach this to a conveyor belt attached
the gifts we wanted this to be something
cool the kids had never seen before this
is an old vintage chestnut roaster that
looks like a little train and we have
the track and if you follow the track
it's a mural that Linda painted for the
holidays of the train going off into the
world they are very merry display is
just one of HGTV's
outrageous holiday houses the special is
executive produced by Drew and his
property brother Jonathan and hosted by
Lance Bass it's a look at some of the
craziest Christmas decorations you've
ever seen including this place decked
out in over 60,000 ornaments wow this is
incredible I love that this space is a
complete mess but it's messy with candy
and sugar and wrapping paper and bows
and all good things related to Christmas
and you can't forget Santa's list we
don't know yet if it's the naughty or
nice list Jonathan right there it's an I
list
[Music]